[موسيقى]
عندما
فقدت بصري ، كان خوفي الأكبر
هو فقدان استقلالي
عندما كان عمري 11 عامًا ، وضربت عيني اليسرى
على جانب حمام السباحة
بعد ذلك فقدت
بصري تدريجيًا وبحلول سن 14 أصبحت
أعمى تمامًا  تشيكو أساكاوا
هي عالمة كمبيوتر في شركة آي بي إم ، وهي
تقسم وقتها بين الولايات المتحدة
واليابان التي
تسافر في منتصف الطريق عبر العالم
والعودة على أساس شهري ،
ولا أرتاح أبدًا عندما أسافر بمفردي لأنني
أعمى يعني أن العبور عبر القارات
لن يكون عملاً عاديًا إذا لم أفعل.  التركيز يمكنني أن
أفتقد موقعي بسهولة ، وعلينا دائمًا
الانتباه إلى
عالمنا المحيط إذا كانت هناك أي
خطوة أمامنا أو إذا كان هناك
مصعد متحرك ،
وهذا هو السبب في
أن حقيبة الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن أن
تصبح رفيق السفر الأساسي.
الروبوت الملاحي
الذي
سيساعدني في التنقل والذي
سيساعدني بشكل أكثر استقلالية ، سيساعدنا على
تجنب أي عقبة أثناء العمل في
مدينة
مليئة بالكاميرات وأجهزة الاستشعار
مثل التكنولوجيا الموجودة  n على متن
سيارة مستقلة
حقيبة حقيبة أساكاوا هي مشروع مشترك
بين جامعة كارنيجي ميلون
والكاميرا التالية من آي بي إم
ستحسب المسافة بيني
وبين العائق المستهدف وهذا
مستشعر ليزر ثلاثي الأبعاد ،
ثم انتقل إلى المكتب وقم بالركض على ما يرام ، اذهب
إلى المدخل
بمجرد الوجهة  تمت برمجة
الحقيبة التي تحدد أفضل مسار ثم
توجه مستخدميها بالاهتزازات على
مقبض الحقيبة
جيدًا يبدو الأمر مقارنة
بالعصا البيضاء
أو الكلب الإرشادي أن الحقيبة الذكية
هي مغير كلي للعبة
نعم نعم
أولاً أشعر أن الحقيبة الذكية ستفعل
افتح عالمًا جديدًا تمامًا
للأشخاص المعاقين بصريًا ،
ولست مضطرًا لطلب أي مساعدة ،
ولا أشعر بأي ضغط على الإطلاق ، أشعر
أنني أستطيع أن أكون مستقلاً ، حتى أنني أشعر أنني
أستطيع الاستمتاع بالتسوق عبر النوافذ بنفسي ،
وأصر على عدم القيام بذلك  اسمح
لحادثتها بتعريف أساكاوا ، فقد أمضت حياتها
المكرسة لجعل الوصول إلى العالم
أكثر سهولة ، لقد طورت
العديد من التقنيات المساعدة
للمعاقين بصريًا.
جوائز الصناعة والحكومة نفسها
مثل دخولها إلى
قاعة مشاهير المخترعين الوطنيين في الولايات المتحدة في عام 2019.
ما هي آمالك للمستقبل
مع الحقيبة الذكية التي تعرف كيف
تعتقد أنها ستتطور بينما
تستمر في تطويرها ،
وأنا أعلم  أن المستشعرات والأجزاء الميكانيكية أصبحت
أصغر وأقوى ، لذا
أريد أولاً أن أجعلها أخف وزناً
وأصغر حتى أتمكن من اصطحاب
الحقيبة الذكية في أي مكان في المدينة
أو عندما أسافر